yeah some guys just like whipping it out  that's wild yeah I think guys get  confused because ladies sometimes you  like a penis so I think guys think hey  she liked one last night why wouldn't  you like one by the copy machine women  are so complex  because I think generally speaking men  are a little more constant you know like  men like boobs but we like boobs across  the board you know yeah boob in the  bedroom great  boob on the bus  also great  penis in the bedroom great penis on the  bus  call the police  nobody's calling the police on a boob  you see a boob out in the wild it's like  seeing a deer you're like  it's Majestic then your friend walks up  hey look at that a boob you're like ah  you spooked it  thanks a lot I'm Kevin Hart